as a stunt is one of the most lame
looking off-camera stunts she learned to
direct improvised one of the best
on-screen moments and worked with a
whole lot of legends
yeah no way home was a good one for
zendaya we've got the scoop on
everything she experienced as part of
the spidey crew in no way home
number one she's got a vision and that
vision holds a future where we seasoned
daya directing the actress was on set
filming her own stuff but even when she
wasn't needed zee requested permission
to hang around i was coming in every day
on set to watch john work the actress
would be hanging out in a corner asking
questions when she knew she wouldn't
cause too much of a disturbance and
soaking in all that valuable knowledge
things great and lovely and shared so
much with me learning on the job is the
best way to do it and with john watts as
a mentor well z is in good hands and we
can't wait to see what she brings to the
table as a director number two
she was on a roll
okay that was a bad pun but she made a
similar one herself on set using a bun
for her punchline for rolling all jokes
aside this improvised moment turned out
to be a fan favorite gem that's right
zendaya was never supposed to be
hurtling buns at andrew garfield's
spider-man initially it could have been
a lot worse though garfield explaining
that zendaya had at first grabbed a
candle stick to threaten him with yikes
fortunately the bread basket was close
by and when she asked john watts if she
could throw bread at him once gave her
the only reasonable answer yeah throw
bread at him it made for some fun while
filming but zee did get a taste of her
own medicine from garfield
number three
she didn't know what she was walking in
on jamie was hosting a dance party the
mj actress spent a lot of time on set
but at a certain point the productions
started to fall behind so they tried to
make sure everyone was laser focused
they're like listen we don't think that
he should have any distractions blah
blah blah maybe it's best not to come in
for a couple days and i was like
okay like that's no problem
and it wouldn't have been a problem
except that just a few days later
zendaya dropped into the no way home
world only to witness a scene that was
very far from focused i literally walk
on set and there is
lights
were going rihanna was playing and the
producers the actor everybody was
dancing the actress didn't even get an
invite
and she was the distraction production
was worried about maybe this is why
we're behind guys yeah number four
flying through the air via web didn't
mean spider-man was the only one working
hard zendaya had to pull her weight too
she would catch me
with the two actors having a height
difference well it didn't really set
them up for success in terms of the
superhero being in control it was up to
zendaya to nail that landing
we were attached i would land before him
my feet obviously hit the ground before
he does and while most of the time she
managed it well she didn't always stick
it number five also known as the
giggling trio the majority of the bts
footage from no way home typically
involves endless laughter from zendaya
tom and jacob i don't think we're like
attempting to make each other laugh so
much as laughing at each other and then
we make the jokes and then it gets
funnier and funnier yeah and that they
did to the point that it became a bit
stressful for director john watts to
actually keep them under control and
focused while filming number six first
day of filming why not dive into the
deep end a scissor lift rigged up 55
feet in the air versus zendaya the
actress pulled off a not so casual
50-foot free-fall like a champ with just
nine feet of the fall being decelerated
as she descended to the ground
fortunately zee was in great hands and
knew the production team did everything
they could to ensure the safety of their
performers
number seven it wasn't what she was
expecting that's for sure zendaya and
tom holland grew close good thing since
they got very intimate at times and not
in the way you might think with a spidey
suit like that well it's hard to control
all your bodily functions i felt the
rattle sorry about that yep zendaya was
right up close and personal with tom
when he let a little something slip but
for these pros no big deal
number eight cool on screen weird behind
the scenes the major stunts in action
sequences are anything but cool without
the cg mj's big fall
not as intense behind the scenes the
actress explained it's funny because
doing something like that doesn't feel
emotional it's just kind of dumb she
spent way less time feeling heartbreak
than she did looking like a turtle stuck
on its back number nine teamwork makes
the dream work as much as spider-man is
the superhero he couldn't be the person
he is without his two besties by his
side tom holland requested zendaya and
jacob be on set with him for
particularly nerve-wracking times
it was so funny that first day i was
like nervous for you it was the day of
the spidey's meeting so the pressure was
really on
me and jacob felt like your parents
like dropping you over kindergarten for
the first day and it's like i hope the
other kids like him tom even described
zendaya as his cheerleader i was taking
pictures of you guys so that you could
have it and it was so cute the actors
always had his best interests at heart
especially when it came to his safety i
always have this fear that if he's like
working really hard or something's
happening that if he had to like throw
up per se
what's the pow
how is he going to get it out
this is a genuine concern number 10 so
close and yet so far while she got to do
a lot of cool things on set jealousy did
settle in when she missed out on working
with certain actors on screen i was
there for behind the scenes watching you
guys oh yeah but i didn't get to know he
gets beaten
luckily she got to know charlie cox
off-screen and who knows what the mcu
future holds
number 11 this was the journey of a
lifetime zendaya was just a teenager
when she started the trilogy so wrapping
it up as an adult was bittersweet
i think we have memories and experiences
that no one else has been able to have
except for us three like the spidey
sandwich swing the spider-man story was
especially significant for her because
she really did understand what it is to
be a young person leading a double life
and carrying more pressure than they
should at their age
number 12. saying goodbye is never easy
we could barely keep ourselves together
regularly crying through the last film
so no surprise india was wildly
emotional shedding tears both on set and
while she was watching her initial
thoughts after filming this is awfully
sad
ain't that the truth it was an epic
journey after all
filming this trilogy was an experience
zendaya will never forget and those
relationships they're bound to last a
lifetime what was your favorite mj scene
in no way home